Today, not much of
a response from Texas Republicans
after the impeachment
of one of their own,
Attorney General Ken Paxton.
One of the open ended questions
will his wife
who is a state senator,
recuse herself from the trial
or will she join her colleagues
in determining
whether her husband
gets to stay in office?
As CNN's Ed
Lavandera reports, the trial
in the state
Senate is expected to take place
this summer.
The articles of impeachment,
the group of Texas House members
who will present the evidence
in the trial of Attorney
General Ken
Paxton
delivered the articles of impeachment
to the state Senate.
It's been 106 years
since the last statewide office
holder in Texas was impeached.
Back then,
it was a governor named James Ferguson
who was known as poor.
Lieutenant Governor Dan
Patrick says a committee of senators
will establish the rules
for the trial in the coming weeks.
But beyond that, Patrick is refusing
to answer questions
about the fellow Republican
who he's worked closely
with since Paxton was elected.
In 2014.
There will be witnesses
and they will be put under oath
and they will be cross-examined,
I'm sure, by both sides.
And it will be a regular trial.
And at the end of that trial,
once the facts are laid out,
the senators will vote.
The upcoming summer of impeachment
in Texas
is exposing the political fault lines
within the state's Republican Party.
Ken Paxton's
allies are targeting House Speaker
David Phelan,
the Republican who presided over
the impeachment vote.
Is unapologetic
about the 20 articles of impeachment
brought against the attorney general
and the Texas House spokesman.
And we sent a strong message
for the future of Texas.
A House
committee started
investigating Paxton in March
after he requested $3.3 million
in taxpayer
funds to pay for a legal settlement
stemming from a lawsuit
brought by whistleblower
who alleged improper behavior
involving a prominent campaign donor.
The articles of impeachment
go further into a pattern of corruption,
including bribery,
obstruction, of justice,
and allegations
of an extramarital affair.
The attorney general
has been temporarily removed from office
and denies any wrongdoing.
This shameful process was curated
from the start
as an act of political retribution.
We all love Ken Paxton
around these parts, right?
Paxton is hoping to generate grassroots
support like this
rally held in his home county
in hopes of winning
over the state senators
who will decide his fate.
Every politician who supports this deceit
fall impeachment attempt
will then flecked
lasting damage
on the credibility of the Texas House.
Paxton's wife, Angela
Paxton, is a state senator,
and there are calls for her
to recuse herself from the trial.
She has not said what she will do.
A group of 12 House
representatives will present the evidence
against Ken Paxton.
The majority of them Republicans.
This is about facts
and this is about evidence.
And at the end of the day,
my colleagues
and I will not stand
for public corruption.
And that's
why we're proceeding to a trial
in the Texas Senate.
And Jake, Ken
Paxton is also accused
of calling House members
before the impeachment vote,
threatening him, threatening them to vote
for him in that vote.
The lead at the head of the House
committee that brought the impeachment
articles of impeachment
against him was asked
if this could lead to further
articles of impeachment
and he would refuse to answer
that question as well.